how do you like your fragrance how about
musty with notes of racism and cultural
appropriation fashion giant do spotted a
gap in the market for an ad campaign
drawing on colonial ideas about Native
Americans and decided it would happily
fill it so it depicted its fragrance
Sauvage a word which means wild in
French but shares a common origin with
English concepts of savage with brand
ambassador Johnny Depp in the desert
while the Native American dancer and
actress performed in the wilderness it
even claimed to be capable of a journey
deep into the authentic Native American
soul I don't know what's more disturbing
the fact that you're came up with this
or that they thought it would sell the
only wild thing about this ad is how
culturally insensitive insulting and
racist it is imagine I know that you
have something to say but before you do
let's have a look at that so people know
exactly what we're speaking about here
is the savage campaign
[Music]
yes looks like quite steep and I think
the critique was both what people
described as the kind of feathers and
leathers to picture of Native American
culture but also the idea of co-opting
that culture for a fragrance that is
called it's difficult to see that name
without thinking the point is that there
are there's a history of depictions of
Native Americans on American television
we all grew up that was basically you
know cowboys and Indians shoot the bad
guys dehumanized in media referred to as
Injuns referred to as savages these are
words that were actually use and so for
the native population in the United
States of America seeing their
traditions juxtaposed with the word
savage resonates on a deeper level which
I think we do need to try and understand
the fashion houses have been somewhat I
think ignorant in the way they've
addressed some of these themes there was
the recent Dolce and Gabanna thing in
China where they had to apologize
profusely because they try to depict a
Chinese model trying to eat Italian food
with chopsticks I think they're
tone-deaf and I think they do need to be
a bit more especially these continental
European houses a bit more sensitive to
certain words that have been
historically used in media to depict
people in a bad light well of course
you're all absolutely right oh yeah well
I mean Johnny Depp should never work
again
Hollywood should I never give him
another film he should probably we
should probably boycott all this oh no I
agree with you just as I agree that
former love island contestant Megan
Barton Hansen with cornrows was wrong
Rhodri the coalmine on a packet of Welsh
crisp was wrong stew
wearing sombreros is wrong jamie
oliver's jerk rice M&S fake biryani for
the love of all that's holy haven't you
three got things to worry about cultural
appropriation which is not a word either
of us used the dancer there were two
natives featured in we need to here
opportunity want to say something this
is what they said the perfumes christian
dior project is part of a io advance in
the genitive campaign to change the
misperceptions about native americans to
share accurate american history
to build awareness about native
americans as contemporary peoples and to
promote indigenous worldviews Parfums
christian dior were very open to
learning about contemporary native
peoples and were committed to avoiding
cultural appropriation so they did it in
consultation with what i will say is it
will still you know though they tried i
acknowledge they tried it was so
tone-deaf the dear you've just said
worked with this very very
well-respected consulting group called
Americans for Indian opportunity Native
Americans were very much part of the
productions there was a native advisor
on the set at all times and the girl you
saw on there a girl called Tommy but you
say she's been on social media slating
what she actually says here she says
dear or she believes although misguided
had every intention of sharing
indigenous culture and a beautiful light
while giving jobs to some Indians in the
process and isn't that the point
you know this cultural appropriation
nonsense drives me nuts if you live in a
multicultural society what you call
cultural appropriation is inevitable I
don't call it cultural protest I call it
appreciating and admiring stupid to
imagine we can't admire or borrow from
other people let me it's ridiculous to
suggest we can't we can't borrow or
admire other people's cultures without
insulting
you've just revealed that you do not
understand the distinction between
cultural exchange and cultural
appropriation which is an important
distinction and one that's central to
this I saw a documentary a few years ago
it's called inventing the Indian and it
was by rich hall in Dallas called
tooth and it explained the history of
what magic was referring to the
depiction of Native Americans a terrible
stereotyping that went on in Hollywood
and on screens that reminded me a little
bit of real bad Arabs which was made
earlier and it was depicting it was by
Jack Shaheen and it was about the same
thing the way that people from the
Middle East basically either belly
dancers or terrorist bombers on screen
all the time that's great nobody's
talking about that but when there when
there is a power dynamic when there is a
structural imbalance so let me finish
when countries and peoples were
subjugated on the basis of a power
dynamic that meant that they were
portrayed as inferior as uncivilized as
barbarian as savvy none of that on their
obvious dancing when a company like Deal
will make something for profit
obviously that dynamic is going to play
into it
and is completely insensate so I
personally object to this for me just
because the word savage took juxtapose
next to a native on the appropriation
argument I'm not so I just think it's a
bit too in-your-face to put this word
Sauvage next to next to a native who's
been historically called that as a
pejorative let's see what House of deal
actually say the campaign was inspired
by the deep and rich nature of the
Native American heritage and culture
which the House of Dior holds in the
highest regard the house of deal work
closely with Native American consultants
artists writers and dancers as well as
the Americans for Indian opportunity to
ensure accuracy and inclusion they go on
in acknowledgment of these reactions the
trailer has now been removed and the new
campaign will be released later these
don't know what I'm getting you for
Christmas now we could talk about this
more but we won't today because before
we go there's just time for this new to
the job no real experience no I'm not
talking about our new prime
one man who truly knows the meaning of a
do-or-die strategy is Australian max
Sylvester the trainee pilot was taking
part in his first ever flying lesson
when his teacher passed out mid-flight
rather than panic quick thinking max
worked out how to pull an air traffic
operator he was able to talk him through
how to make an emergency landing after
nearly an hour max safely landed the
plane and his instructor was taken off
to hospital where he's making recovery
here's what max had to say about the
experience situation that you've been a
bit of an inspiration to a lot of people
max you are a have a go hero of the week
I can't how to ring the traffic control
don't forget you can join in the debate
just search for the pledge on Twitter to
have your say and the pledge is also
available to listen to you every week
find us on Apple podcasts google
podcasts or the sky news app thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]